SCP-682 Vs SCP-923. Can this terrifying,
mind-melting satellite finally drive SCP-682
off the edge? Foundation researchers damaged
682 heavily and took it out to an isolated
field in Kansas in order to find out.
SCP-923 fired down at 682 with its
beam set to Intensity level 75,
known to have devastating effects against
the minds of its victims. When the blast was
unleashed, 682 began screaming and howling
obscenities at the sky and the Foundation.
Then, its body began to adapt, growing
glowing nodes that fired out its own beams
similar to 923’s blasts, driving the observing
Foundation employees completely insane.
The test was considered such a failure
that one of the lead researchers on the
SCP-682 termination project threatened to do
something REDACTED to whoever organized it.